150 years after darwin's publication of
the Origin of Species evolutionary
biology continues to be an exciting
field of scientific research and
discovery Darwin's theory of natural
selection involved inheritance of
variation from adult to offspring Darwin
never knew the exact mechanism for this
genetic inheritance today we know it as
DNA Darwin had a tremendously good
intuition about how the world works and
what's remarkable to me is that he was
able to devise a very clever outlook on
all of this with really very rudimentary
information he could look at how
organisms were distributed for example
on the globe and look at the details of
how barnacles were constructed from
those kinds of observations he was able
to extract a very general theory of how
this all worked and you know the notion
of natural selection the notion of the
tree of life emerged from these kind of
detailed observations today evolutionary
biologists can test ideas about
evolution experimentally by watching it
happen in a laboratory studying the
simplest organisms of all microscopic
viruses that Darwin never knew existed
scientists are able to investigate
evolution at the molecular level
Darwin's work on natural selection is
essential to our understanding of the
way viruses evolved it completely
accounts for the kinds of traits that we
can measure in the laboratory the traits
that viruses show and the way that they
change through time before our very eyes
when we create environments in the
laboratory and challenge a virus
population with becoming better adapted
to those environments the way that they
change is entirely described
through natural selection experimental
understanding of how evolution works
will help in the discovery of new
medicines and therapies to combat
infectious diseases and in the
laboratory what we try to do is look at
the evolution of viruses get a better
understanding of how they evolve what
are the circumstances that make them
vulnerable to intervention by certain
therapies and then we try to especially
capitalize on those types of therapies
to control epidemics and to prevent the
spread of viruses building on Darwin's
theories scientists are taking
evolutionary biology into new and
exciting directions that Darwin could
never have imagined I would love to
bring Darwin into my lab to show him
that he was right on with understanding
how natural selection proceeds even
though he didn't have a very good
understanding he didn't have much of an
understanding at all of what it was that
was being passed between generations to
be able to show him what DNA looks like
how we can easily obtain it from real
organisms how we can look at differences
in DNA for individuals in a population
that is the variation that he talked
about as necessary to drive natural
selection rapid evolution can be seen in
living creatures larger than viruses as
well scientists are studying toads that
are evolving right in front of our eyes
one of the most curious things about
Darwin's work is he believed
fundamentally that change in the natural
world the kind of change that would lead
to speciation formation of new species
was gradual it was slow it would take a
long period of time whereas what we know
today is that evolution can happen very
rapidly it can happen right on the same
pace with environmental changes even
very rapid environmental changes some
very good examples have come from study
of amphibians and reptiles and there's
there's one that really stands out and
that's the cane toad so cane toads were
introduced into Australia in 1935 they
come from Central and South America they
like relatively humid relatively wet
jungle II sorts of places and yet most
of Australia is not like
you don't have to get too far into the
interior and it starts to get pretty dry
the cane toads didn't seem to understand
that they weren't supposed to be living
in this much drier environment and at
the point where people expected them to
stop moving based on where they were
able to live in their native range they
were moving faster and faster cane toads
were in fact evolving what looks like it
happened is as they moved into this
dryer environment they were getting
longer legs they moved faster they also
were affecting the predator populations
there so as snakes would eat the cane
toads if they got a big enough dose of
this toxin they died the surviving
snakes and their descendants had smaller
heads so not only do we have the cane
toad evolving to deal with this new
environment but these predators these
kind of bystander species were evolving
in response to this invader today
evolutionary biologists continue to
build upon Darwin's legacy further
developing his theories with novel
discoveries new tools and fresh insights
I think the base paradigm that Darwin
laid out for us has survived the first
150 years extremely well and I think
there's every reason to believe that a
hundred years from now the core of it is
still going to be just as useful the
fact that this idea could survive and in
fact be strengthened by the discovery of
DNA as the mechanism of inheritance and
all we've learned about genetics since
then suggest that that this is a pretty
durable idea